.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GO OVER DAY
AGO IT ALL VERY QUICKLY. FIRST
MOST IMPORTANT LOOK WE'RE NOW
FIVE MONTHS INTO THE
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS THE MOST
CENTRAL THING WE CAN DO IN NEW
YORK CITY IS KEEP OURSELVES
HEALTHY. KEEP THE INFECTION
RATE LOW IN THIS CITY IF WE GET
THAT PART RIGHT AND YOUR
PRESIDENT HEROES FIGHTING BACK
AGAINST THIS DISEASE WE KEEP
THIS AT A LOW LEVEL. EVERYTHING
ELSE BECOMES POSSIBLE
RESTARTING OUR CITY RESTARTING
OUR ECONOMY IT ALL DEPENDS ON
THIS SO. WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
SEVERAL THINGS TODAY BUT ONE
VERY VERY IMPORTANT HE'S
EQUATION IS THE OFFENSE HERE
THE FORCE THAT WE PUT TOGETHER
FIGHT BACK AGAINST THE DISEASE
THE TESTING TRACE CORE WE'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT THE LATEST ON
THAT AND HOW IT'S HELPING US
KEEP THAT AFFECTS LEVEL. BUT I
WANT TO FIRST TALK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IMPORTANT
PIECES THAT ARE HAPPY TODAY
THAT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
PERSONAL QUESTION FICTIONS
RESIGNING AND OF THOUSANDS
THOUSANDS OF ORDERS PEOPLE JUST
TRY TO KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD. WELL WE HAVE SOME NEWS
CHANNEL THANK GOD CUOMO PRIME.
EXTENDING A OF THE PART.
AGAINST OF. FOR TEN AS A OF
COKE NINETEEN. NOW WE NEED THE
JUST TO PLAY THERE ALSO CALLING
ON STATE OF COURT SYSTEM
PLEASE. AGGRESSIVELY FOLLOW UP
ON THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
PROTECT. TENANTS WHO SIMPLY
CAN'T PAY THE RENT BECAUSE THEY
LOST THEIR INCOME DUE TO. THE
GREATEST CRISIS IN GENERATIONS.
WE NEED THE COURT SYSTEM TO
COME IN AND THEN WE NEED THE
STATE IN GENERAL TO ADDRESS THE
BIT OF QUESTIONS HERE THESE
ELECTION- MORATORIUMS. I SHOULD
NOT BE A SOMETHING THAT JUST
HAS TO BE RENEWED ALL THE TIME
THIS NEEDS TO BE ONGOING FOR
THE NEXT. PRICE AT. THE MOMENT
THERE. AS PEOPLE. WE
CONSISTENTLY BACK ON THEIR FEET.
AND HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY THEIR
REALLY WHAT WE NEED. ARE THE
STAPLES. TEN ASSISTS WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS THAT PEOPLE GET.
AND WE THE STATE TO PASS A LAW
GIVING TENANTS THE BILL TO THE
RENT THEY CAN IF THEY DON'T ANY
INCOME WHAT CAN I DO. FOR THOSE
WHO DON'T HAVE INCOME GIVING
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO ON A
PAYMENT PLAN AND PAY BACK WHEN
THEY DO THAT'S RIGHT FOR
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS ALIKE WE
NEED STATE ACTION ON THAT
FRONT. NOW LET'S TALK ABOUT SO
MUCH HAS HAPPENED LAST FEW DAYS
WITH THE STORM THAT HIT THIS
CITY SCIENCE. FIRST OF ALL THE
ONGOING POWER OUTAGES THIS IS
AN UNACCEPTABLE SITUATION- CON
ED CONTINUES TO BE UNCLEAR IN
THEIR RESPONSE AND THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'VE SEEN BEFORE AND
I REALLY WISH KANYE WILL GET
THEM ALL. AFTER CLEARER IN THE
DAY PLAN FOR YOUR PEOPLE
DEPENDING ON THIS POWER. OF THE
POWER HAS COME BACK ON
CONSISTENTLY I WANT TO GIVE
THAT CREDIT BUT I'M NOT HAPPY
ABOUT IS A LACK OF CLARITY AND
SPEED ABOUT THE NEXT STEPS FOR
THE PEOPLE OF THE FIVE BOROUGHS
TO WRITE. NOW I JUST ABOUT
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS. DO NOT HAVE IN YORK
CITY'S OF THE STORM EARLIER IN
THE WEEK. FROM THE LATEST WE'VE
HEARD FROM CON ED THEY ARE
STILL STICKING TO THE NOTION IT
WILL ADD ANOTHER FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY THOUSAND RESTORATIONS
TODAY SO ANOTHER. FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY THOUSAND. GET A POWER
TODAY BASED ON THE ESTIMATES
WE'VE GOTTEN FROM KANYE. WANT
TO SEE THAT NUMBER GREAT WELL
INTENSIFY. TELLING PEOPLE BUT
ON THE SUNDAY IS A POSSIBLE HE
DOES DO THAT. WHICH FOR THE
BASSMAN. ALSO COM ED'S FEET TO
THE FIRE WE HAVE URGES THEM TO
MOVES FASTER BUT ALSO OFF
WHATEVER. THEY NEED. ALSO YOU
SHOULD KNOW SEPARATE TOTALLY.
SEPARATE WEEK. THERE WERE
WARNING. THE OVER A HUNDRED
COST THAT IS A NEW OUTAGE
APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN A FROM
WHETHER ACT LAST ALL OF THOSE
HAD BEEN RESTORED SO THAT WAS A
VERY BRIEF OUTAGE NOW THERE'S
OTHER DAMAGE OF COURSE FROM THE
STORM THIS IS THE WORST- WINDS
WE HAD SEEN SINCE. AND WE THE
WORST. PERSON TO. ARE WE ARE
WITH THE STATE RIGHT NOW AND I
CERTAINLY WANT TO CALL ON THE
STATE TO. AUTHORIZE AN
EMERGENCY DECLARATION. GIVEN
WHAT'S HAPPENED YORK CITY GIVE
ONE HALF THE LONG ISLAND THIS
CERTAINLY SHOULD BE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND THEN THAT WOULD
HELP TO ACTIVATE FEMA SUPPORT
AND FUNDING NOW. SOME PEOPLE
REACH OUT TO ME AND SAID COULD
FEMA COME IN FEMA IS NOT A
POSITION TO COME IN WITH A LOT
OF RESOURCES THAT WOULD HAVE AN
IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON THE KIND OF
EVENT. THEY OFTEN COORDINATE
THE RESORT OF OTHER LOCAL AND
STATE ENTITIES BUT WHAT I CAN
HELP WITH FOR SURE IS
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE COSTS SO.
WE NEED TO STATE DECORATION
EMERGENCY WE NEED FEMA FUNDING.
TO COVER THE VERY REAL COSTS OF
THIS CLEAN UP. NOW TODAY WILL
HAVE OVER ONE THOUSAND CITY.
STATE NATIONAL GUARD AND
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS WORKING THE
CLEAR EIGHT THREE DASH SO
THAT'S A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF
PERSONNEL WILL BE OUT THERE.
FROM A WIDE RANGE OF THIS THE
AGENT. PART DEPARTMENT ARNELLE
PROTECTION POLICE DEPARTMENT
FIRE DEPARTMENT'S
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT A
NUMBER OF AGENCIES ARE GETTING
INVOLVED COMBINED EFFORTS OVER
A THOUSAND PERSONNEL OUT KHAN
IT. APPARENTLY ABOUT. FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY PERSONAL. OUR
FIRST AND COURSES SAFETY ARE
STILL PLACES WHERE THERE ARE
REAL SAFETY BECAUSE OF THE
POWER. THAT TO BE A PRO TO GET
THOSE LINES SECURED. PEOPLE'S
LIVES. WE ALSO NEED STREETS TO
BE CLEARED AT THIS POINT OF THE
NUMBER STREETS CLEAR BUT
THEY'RE STILL TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY STREETS BLOCKED IN NEW
YORK CITY. WE'LL HAVE OVER TWO
HUNDRED OF THOSE RESOLVED BY
THE END OF THE DAY ACCORDING TO
LATEST INFORMATION FROM THE
PARTS DEPARTMENT THE REST WE
EXPECT TO BE RESOLVED.
HOPEFULLY ON SATURDAY SO A LOT
TO DO THERE WE KEEP MOVING
FORWARD. BUT NOW BACK TO. THE
CENTRAL ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
GRIPPING OUR LIVES FOR THE LAST
FIVE MONTHS HAVE FIGHT THIS
VIRUS. HOW WE KEEP IT FROM
SPREADING OUT WE STOP
RESURGENCE. NEW YORKERS HAVE
BEEN HEROES HAVE BEEN AMAZING
THE WHOLE COUNTRY IS LOOKING
WITH ADMIRATION NEW YORK CITY
FOR THE WAY WE FOUGHT BACK. AND
TESTING TRACE IS A CREW. IS THE
EQUATION AGAIN THIS IS THIS
ARMY OF OVER THREE THOUSAND.
HARD WORKING PEOPLE OUT THERE
EVERY DAY IN COMMUNITIES ON THE
PHONES FINDING PEOPLE HELPING
PEOPLE REACHING PEOPLE.
LITERALLY STOPPING THOUSANDS OF
NEW INFECTIONS WITH THEIR WORK
AND IT'S AN ARMY THAT'S
GROWING. AND PART OF THE MAGIC
HERE IS NOT JUST TO SAY- WE
NEED YOU GET TESTED BUT ALSO IF
YOU ARE. A TESTING POSITIVE. TO
GET YOU THE HELP YOU NEED IF
YOU HAVE TO SAFELY SEPARATE
FROM OTHER CELL PHONE. SING
SING FAST 92% OF ALL POSITIVE
CASES HAVE BEEN REACHED.
THOUSANDS WE NOW ESTIMATE OVER
FIVE THOUSAND POTENTIAL
CORONAVIRUS CASES AVERTED
MEANING FIVE THOUSAND MORE
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
WERE NOT BECAUSE- THE FOLKS WHO
TESTED POSITIVE WERE SAFELY
SEPARATED FROM THE FOLKS AROUND
THEM. BUT WE GOT A LOT MORE TO
DO WITH BIG BIG THINGS COMING
ON FLU SEASON'S COMING COLDER
WEATHER PEOPLE ARE ENDORSED.
SCHOOL COMING BACK A LOT OF
HEADS OF TEST ENTRIES WILL BE
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER. AND
WHEN TESTING FOR CALLS IT MEANS
SOMEONE IS CALLING NOT ONLY
TRYING TO STOP THE DISEASE FROM
SPREADING PROTECT YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY BUT THE TRYING GIVE YOU
HELP. THAT IF YOU NEED TO
SAFELY SET. WILL BE IF YOU
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY AND THE-
LEADING CHARGE THE LEADER OF
THIS PIECE OF THE AFTER. MAKING
PEOPLE. MARK COMPASSION.
RESOURCEFUL THEREFORE WHATEVER
THEY TO GET THROUGH. THAT
PERIOD OF ISOLATION AND GET
HELL AGAIN. THE DIRECTOR OF THE
TAKE CARE INITIATIVE OF.
TESTING TRACE DR ON. JOHNSON
WELCOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MAYOR. AS MY MENTION THAT CARE
ARM OF THE TEST INCREASE COURSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
YOUR CHRIS HAVE WHAT THEY NEED
TO SAFELY SEPARATE TO DATE THIS
PROGRAM HAS LOOKED LIKE HELPING
NEW YORKERS CONNECT WITH HOTELS
SO THAT THEY HAVE A PHYSICAL
SPACE AND AMENITIES THAT THEY
NEED TO PREVENT SPREADING THE
VIRUS I LOVE ONE. NEITHER
FRIENDS FOR NEW YORKERS SHOULD
DELIVER YOU THE SERVICES THAT
YOU NEED TO DO SO FROM THE
COMFORT OF YOUR OWN HOME. WE
ARE REALLY PLEASED. THAT
STARTING NEXT WEEK WILL
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO DELIVER YOU
THE SUPPLIES THAT YOU NEED TO
COMPLETE YOUR SAFE SEPARATION.
IN THE FORM OF ART TAKE CARE
PACKAGE. SO I'M GONNA WALK YOU
THROUGH THE CONTENT OF THIS
PACKAGE SOME OF WHICH ARE GONNA
BE FAMILIAR TO YOU. SO HAVING-
THE STORM OF THE PAST FIVE
MONTHS YOU'LL KNOW THAT THIS IS
A MEDICAL GRADE MASS BUT YOU
CAN USE TO PROTECT YOURSELF
FROM THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO
RESIDE IN YOUR HOMES. WE'VE
ALSO INCLUDED HAND SANITIZER
FOR YOU. NOTHING TAKES THE
PLACE OF WASH YOUR HANDS AS
FREQUENTLY AS POSSIBLE BUT I
JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
REMARK ON HOW. IMPRESSIVE IT IS
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO DELIVER
HAND SANITIZER AND MASKS AT A
TIME WHERE WE WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO SO FIVE MONTHS
AGO. WE ALSO HAVE. A BACTERIAL
WIPES SO THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO
CLEAN THE SURFACES. SO THAT YOU
REDUCE THE RISK OF TRANSMITTING
THE VIRUS TO PEOPLE WHO SHARE
YOUR HOUSEHOLD. WE'RE ALSO
INCLUDING TWO ITEMS TO HELP YOU
WITH MONITORING YOUR HEALTH
DURING THE TIME THAT YOU'RE
ISOLATING QUARANTINING. ONE IS
A DISPOSABLE THERMOMETER THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
YOUR CONTACT TRACERS GOING TO
CALL YOU AND ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR
SYMPTOMS WE SPECIFICALLY WANT
TO KNOW IF YOU'VE REGISTERED
ANY FEVER. OVER THE DAY. THIS
WILL HELP US ENSURE THAT WHEN
IT COMES TIME FOR YOU TO EXIT
YOUR SAFE SEPARATION YOU'RE
ABLE TO DO SO- AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WE'VE ALSO
INCLUDED A MEDICAL DEVICE IN
THE CASE THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
SENDING TWO CASES OF THE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED POSITIVE
FOR COVID. THIS IS A PULSE
OXIMETER. IT GIVES YOU TWO VERY
USEFUL PIECES OF INFORMATION
ONE OF WHICH IS YOUR HEART RATE.
THE OTHER IS YOUR OXYGEN LEVEL
THE LEVEL OF OXYGEN SATURATION
IN YOUR BLOOD. THIS INFORMATION
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE A
LOW OXYGEN SATURATION CAN BE AN
EARLY WARNING SIGN THAT YOU
NEED TO SEEK ADDITIONAL MEDICAL
ATTENTION. YOU CAN HAVE A LOW
OXYGEN SATURATION WITHOUT EVEN
FEELING BREATHLESS SO REALLY
POLICE ARE ABLE TO INCLUDE THIS
BUT YOU HAVE THE INFORMATION
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO ESCALATE
CARE- WHEN THE TIME COMES WHEN
AND IF THE TIME COMES. WE ALSO
THROUGH THE GENEROSITY THROUGH
OF A COUPLE OF DOLLARS MABEL TO
INCLUDE A COUPLE THINGS TO MAKE
THAT DURATION OF SAFE
SEPARATION MORE ENGAGING AND
MORE AFTER. SIR REALLY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THE INCLUSION
OF A COUPLE OF. EIGHT OKAY. TOP
BEING INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO
ACT ONLINE WORKS AND TRAINING I
KNOW THAT WAS A LOT OF
INFORMATION BUT WE ALSO
INCLUDED A BOOKLET IN THAT TAKE
CARE PACKAGE SO THAT YOU CAN GO
OVER THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
INCLUDED AND ALSO FIND
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO
CONNECT WITH OTHER SERVICE THAT
YOU MIGHT NEED THE TIME OF YOUR
SAFE SEPARATION. THIS PACKAGE
IS QUITE TRANSLATED IN THIRTEEN
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES AS WELL.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT BEING ABLE
TO SAFELY SEPARATE COMES OUT TO
MORE THAN JUST TOOLS IT'S ABOUT
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
YOUR CONTACT TRACER WITH YOUR
RESOURCE NAVIGATOR. SO THAT
THEY CAN HELP YOU GET THE
SERVICES THAT YOU NEED TO
SAFELY SEPARATE PARTICULARLY IF
YOU CHOOSE TO DO SO AT HOME.
WE'RE REALLY PROUD OF THE WORK
THAT THE FIFTEEN COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WHO FORM
OUR CORE OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
RESOURCE NAVIGATOR.
RELATIONSHIPS THEY'VE BUILT TO
HELP PEOPLE GET THE SERVICES
THEY NEED WELL THERE SAFELY
SEPARATING AT HOME. THESE
TIRELESS. TWO HUNDRED PLUS
RESEARCH THAT HAVE OVER EIGHT
CALL THE PEOPLE AGREED SERVICE
PEOPLE REACHED OUT TO US. THIS
THE CREDIT. TIME EVEN A TO COME.
AND TOLLS TWO. ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND PLUS CITY SERVICES
INC. GRETCHEN THREE AS WELL AS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE. AND
WE'VE ABLE TO IN. TWO SEND.
HAVE BEEN PARTICIPATING IN THE
TEST INCREASE SO FAR SO IF
YOU'VE GOT IT YOU'VE GOTTEN
TESTED IF YOU PICKED UP THE
PHONE YOUR CONTACT TRACER HAS
CALLED YOU. IF YOU'VE GIVEN
INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR CONTACTS
SO WE CAN HELP THEM KNOW THEIR
STATUS AND HELP THEM SAFELY
SEPARATE. I AM INDEBTED TO YOU
I'M ALSO VERY GRATEFUL FOR
EVERYBODY WHO HAS MADE THE
SACRIFICE SAFELY SEPARATE AT
HOME A HOTEL THAT WE CAN BREAK
THE CHAINS OF TRANSMISSION. AND
STOP VACCINE IT'S EX. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND I'M GONNA TRY TO
BACK TO AMERICA THANK YOU SOME
STOCK IN. ACTUALLY AND EVERYONE
THINK ABOUT WHAT DOCTOR JOHNSON
OVER THERE. IS A VERY VERY CALM
ANSWER SEN. PART TO GET PEOPLE
WHAT SUPPORT THEY NEED WE'RE
NOT SAY THE PEOPLE. ON YOUR OWN
QUITE THE ON WE'RE SAYING WE'RE
GONNA BE WITH YOU AT STEP OF
THE WAY. IN FACT IF YOU. H. THE
TESTING AFTER. A LOT SUPPORT.
COMPACT BLOCKED. ALL SO THANK
YOU DOCTOR FOR YOUR GREAT WORK
AND YOUR TEAM'S WORK. AND LOOK
WE ARE EVER. ABOUT THIS DISEASE
SO WE ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT
WHILE WE'RE SERVING. THAT FOLKS
IN THIS CITY WHO NEED TO SAFELY
SEPARATE WERE ALSO VERY KEENLY
AWARE OF FOLKS TRAVELING IN OR
NEW YORKERS HAVE BEEN TO ONE OF
THE THIRTY FIVE STATES WHERE
THERE ARE PROBLEMS COMING BACK.
THEY NEED TEN TRAYS COURT TO.
IN SOME. NINETEEN INFORMATION.
EVERYBODY A LOT OF WAYS ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'RE DOING IS OUR
CHECK. NOW IS THE RELIGIOUS
WEEK. THIS IS. THIS IS. TO HELP
PEOPLE GET THEM IN FOR. I DON'T
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT. IS THAT
IN THE SITUATION ACCORDING
STATE LAW WOULD SHOULD. THAT
THIS IS. WHAT THIS THE HELP
YOU'LL RECEIVE. BUT ALSO. THE
WORD TO ALL NEW. AND VISITORS
THAT THIS IS. REALLY SO THE
TRUMP WORK BEGAN. WITH THAT
CLEAR MESSAGE. MESSAGE WHERE HE
HELPED BUT WE ARE MAKE SURE A-
TAKE THIS. EVERYONE THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE THEY DO NOT
STATE FARM THE STOCK SWAP ABOUT
TO. VEHICLES JUST AS A TASK.
THAT NUMBER IS GOING TO GROW.
THIS WE CAN BUT ON. IT WILL TO.
REACH THOUSANDS AND- OF PEOPLE
AS- BUT I THINK MILLIONS OF GET
THEM. BICKER THESE CHECK. THAT
IS. MUST BE HONORED FOR THEIR
ALL. LET ME TELL A SNAP TO OUR
IN THE- AT AGAIN THIS MAKES THE-
HOW THE DFSA THE FOLK THE HARD
WORK IN YOUR- EVERYTHING WE'VE
BEEN DOING. INTO TRACED. IS
KEEPING. THESE NUMBERS LOW SO
FIRST NUMBER ADMIT. PERSISTENT
COVER IN THRESHOLD HUNDRED
PATIENT DAYS OF. SEVENTY NINE
PATIENTS. NUMBER TWO THE NUMBER
OF HELP ALSO I SEE YOU. THREE
HUNDRED SET FIVE. PATIENTS IN
THE THRUST THREE HUNDRED TO IS
THE NUMBER TODAY. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY BE. TESTING SYRIA
WIDE FOR. THRESHOLD FIFTEEN PER
DAY REPORT ONE. PERCENT ONE
NUMBER THANK RELATIONS TO A FEW
BIRDS NOT. IS THIS YOUR. I
SKYRAIDERS OKAY MUSKER TOLO
SOLICITOR CALIF A STAND SAY
GOODNESS TORONTO DISTRESS THEY
LOST PREVENT US. WITH THAT WILL
TURN TOWARDS COLLEGE IN THE
MEDIA PLEASE LET ME KNOW THE
NAME AND HOW EVERY JOURNALIST.
HI ALL WE HAVE WITH US HERE
TODAY DOCTOR AMANDA JOHNSON
DIRECTOR OF TAKE CARE IN THE
TEST ENTRY SCORE. DEPUTY MAYOR
FOR OPERATIONS AND PARKS
COMMISSIONER SILVER EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMISSIONER CHRIS
WELL SURE FACEBO AND SENIOR
ADVISOR DR VARMA. WITH THAT
I'LL START WITH DAVE EVANS FROM
ABC SEVEN. DAVID ACT YES I'M
HERE CAN YOU GO HOW YOU DOING
DAVE. I'M PRIMERICA HEY I WANT
TO ASK YOU FIRST OF ALL A ABOUT
THE SCHOOL THAT SOUNDS LIKE WE
MIGHT HAVE SOME USE FROM THE
GOVERNOR LATER I DON'T KNOW HOW
EARTH SHOW IT GONNA BE BUT THE
WANT TO SEE REACTION. YEAH IT'S
GOING TO BE A REACH BY REGION
SAYING UP WHAT METRIC IS.
REGION OF THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WITH THE INFECTION RATE- SO WE
COULD HAVE THIS IN ALBANY I
GUESS OPEN MAYBE THE SCHOOLS IN
NEW YORK CITY NOT OPEN BUT- THE
WORD TO PURSUE IT AND ACT AS IF
WE- IN SCHOOLS. COOL THE FOR.
THE CALLED IN SEPTEMBER IF THAT
IS THAT YOUR UNDERSTANDING
GONNA BE HALF DAVE YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS ON
EVERYONE'S MINDS WE I'M NOT A
COMMON TO WE GET THE FORMAL-
FORMAL DECISIONS FROM THE STATE
BUT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CLOSE
COOPERATION BETWEEN THE STATE
AND CITY ON THE NOTION OF TOUGH
THREAT. NJ DURING THE
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS- THERE'S
BEEN REAL UNITY ON THE NOTION
THAT WE WERE GOING TO BE VERY
CAREFUL TOUGH AND DECIDE WHEN
2% THROUGH EACH PHASE YOU KNOW
WE WENT THROUGH PHASES ONE TO
THREE FOUR ON TOP WITH OPTIONS
IN THE CITY WHERE YOUR- EXCEPT.
COOL THEY ARE NOT. I WANT TO
HOLD YOUR TO. ERIC TANNER NAT
THREE STANDARD. A SEVEN DAY
PERIOD OF OUR AVERAGE GOES
ABOVE 3% AFFECTION IN NEW YORK
CITY WE WOULD NOT OPEN SCHOOLS
OF THE HAPPENED DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR WE WILL CLOSE THEM.
SO YOU KNOW I BELIEVE ALL GONNA
BE YOUR FIGHT ON THAT AND
VIGILANT- WE NEED TO OPEN
SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE KNOW- JUST
EXTRAORDINARY NUMBER WE ONE
POINT ONE MILLION SCHOOL KIDS.
AND THREE QUARTERS OF FAMILIES
HAVE SAID THEY WANT THE KIDS
BACK IN SCHOOL THEY WANT THAT
SUPPORT THEY WANT KIDS TO
BETTER EDUCATIONALLY THAN THEY
CAN DO REMOTELY THEY WANT
EVERYTHING TO GOES TO SCHOOL
THE SOCIAL ELEMENT IN HOUSE.
PHYSICAL HEALTH SERVICES FOOD
OUR OBLIGATION TO DO OUR VERY
BEST FOR PARENTS AND FAMILIES.
ARE BOTH GOING TO WORK WITH THE
STATE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IF
THAT'S WHAT COUNTS MOST. GOING
NO MATTER WHERE TULSA TO DO
WITH I THINK TODAY IS DAY THAT
THAT PARENTS HAVE TO THE IF
THERE ARE GONNA HOME AND LET
FROM ONLINE I'M NOT GOING TO
CLASS BUT MY QUESTION IS I KNOW
YOU PROBABLY HAVE HEARD THIS
BEFORE IT'S KIND OF DIFFICULT
TO MAKE THAT DECISION AT THE
NET IF THE PARENTS DON'T REALLY
KNOW. WHAT THE CLASSROOM
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS FALL
TWENTY DAY I'LL STATE THAT IS
BOTH BANKS WELL I'LL TAKE
COUPLE THINGS AND I WAS PUBLIC
SCHOOL PARENT FOR IN HIGHER
EDUCATION OF BOTH KIDS ARE
STRICTLY FOR TWO THE MANY MANY
PARENTS ARE GOING THROUGH NOW
MADE SOMEWHAT FORCED AND REALLY
TOUGH. BUT I ALSO THINK. NEW
YORK'S PARENTS REALISTS
UNDERSTAND WE'VE GONE TO DOES.
LIKE NEVER BEFORE ARE IN AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO LOOK LIKE A
NORMAL YEAR. BUT HERE'S THE
DEAL- PEOPLE HAVE TO THE END OF
THE DAY TO INDICATE IF THEY
WANT TO GO WITH ALL REMOTE FROM
THE BEGINNING WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT MONDAY WILL GIVE AN UPDATE
ONCE THOSE NUMBERS. ARE
TABULATED- THE- TODAY POINT
PARENTS CAN MAKE THAT DECISION
AND THEY CAN GO TO REMOTE-
PRETTY MUCH INSTANTLY ALONG THE
WAY IF THEY NEED TO. BUT WE
ALSO KNOW A SURVEY OF FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PARENTS IS
UNHEARD OF TO GET THAT KIND OF
RESPONSE RATE THAT- MOST
PARENTS BY FAR ONE OF THE KIDS
BACK IN SCHOOL THEY UNDERSTAND
IT'S GOING TO BE BLENDED
LEARNING. FOR THE SHORT TERM.
AND THEY ALL KEEP SAYING
THERE'S NOT FOREVER. YOU KNOW
FIVE MONTHS SIX MONTHS SEVEN
MONTHS I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHEN BUT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
DAY WHEN THERE'S A VACCINE AND
KIDS HAVE IT AND THINGS ARE
BACK TO NORMAL BUSINESS I HOPE
ONLY PART OF OUR SCHOOL YEAR.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE GETS
AFFECTED BY THE CORONAVIRUS.
BUT AIDE THINKING THROUGH THE
PERSPECTIVE OF PARENTS I'D SAY
THIS. YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW- IF
YOU CHOOSE TO HAVE KIDS IN
SCHOOL YOU KNOW SOME DAYS A
WEEK. ARE IN THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS YOU'RE GONNA
GET ALL THE DETAILS ABOUT YOUR
SCHOOL'S SCHEDULE TEMPLATE AND
THEN YOUR INDIVIDUAL CHILD'S
SCHEDULE. YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE PROVIDING CHILDCARE
FOR AS MANY PEOPLE AS WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TRYING BILL THAT
NUMBER UP. AND PARENTS ARE
USING ALL THE RESOURCES OF
THEIR COMMANDER FAMILY FRIENDS
FELLOW PARENTS ARE ALL GOING TO
WORK TOGETHER. WILL NOT BE
EASY. BUT I THINK MOST PARENTS
FEEL STRONG THAT EVEN SOME TIME
IN SCHOOL IS A LOT BETTER FOR
KIDS THAN NON. WE HAVE DAVID IN
THE QUEEN'S DAILY EAGLE. HI MR
MAYOR TWO QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS- YES THREE TALK
ABOUT CONTINUING TO HOUSE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
COMMERCIAL HOTELS. GRETCHEN AND
CRISIS TO LIMIT COVID IN
CONCRETE SHELTERS COMMISSIONER
BANKS SAID THEY'RE MEANT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND ADULTS MOVED
INTO TWO BEDROOM- TWO BEDROOMS
THAT SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED ROOMS
DHSS AVERAGES. TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS A NIGHT
WITH SERVICES THAT'S MORE THAN
MILLION HALF DOLLARS A NIGHT
FORTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS A
MONTH AT THE STOP CAPSULE SO.
OFFICIALS YOUR TREATMENT.
BURNING L. THANK EITHER. S. R.
O. R. HOTELS INTO. SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING SITES SO WILL THIS DO
THE- AND WHAT IS THE LONG TERM
PLAN FOR PEOPLE STAYING IN. DAY
LOCK EARLY IN YOUR RESEARCH I
APPRECIATE THAT- YEAH THE GOAL
HERE CONTINUES TO BE TO DEAL
WITH THE SHORT TERM. H. I'M
JUST GONNA USE AROUND NUMBER.
R. WHILE WE'RE DEALING WITH
THIS CRISIS UNTIL PEOPLE ARE
VACCINATED THEN ONCE WE GET
THROUGH AT INTO START TO MOVE
OUT OF THOSE HOTELS AND GO BACK
INTO THE SHELTER SYSTEM. BUT
WE'RE CONSTANTLY TRYING TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
SHELTERS AND ALL THE OTHER
TOOLS WE HAVE WHILE A LOT MORE
TO SAY ON THAT IN THE COMING
WEEKS BUT I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO NOT ATTEND. EIGHT YOU CAN'T.
GET TO A- BETTER. YES IF WE
HAVE CAN OF A AND IT'S NO
LONGER NEEDED TO FOR SHELTER
THE GOAL IS ALWAYS TO CONVERTED
TO PERMANENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO HAVE ENOUGH
SHELTER AVAILABLE BY LAW AND
MORALLY FOR FOLKS WHO NEED IT.
SO DIFFERENT PIECES THE ANSWER
BUT I THINK THE SIMPLE POINT IS
JOB ONE IS GET FOLKS OUT OF THE
HOTELS HAVE BEEN IN TEMPORARILY
ARE BACK IN THE SHELTER SYSTEM
ONCE IT'S GOT. SO YOU SUPPORT A
NEW NASCAR A LAW TO. ALLOW
THOSE HOTELS TO BE CONVERTED TO
PERMANENT USE. WELL AGAIN THE
ONES THAT THERE ARE THERE ARE
BUILDINGS WE CONTROL ALREADY-
AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE LOOKING
TO OR WANT TO CONTROL WANT TO
PURCHASE WHERE WE'RE LOOKING TO
DO PERMANENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. I THINK IN TERMS S. R.
L. LAW I HAVE TO I HAVE TO
CHECK THAT AND I THINK THERE'S
SOME OPEN QUESTIONS THERE AND
SOME WILL COME BACK ON. I WILL
SAY TO YOU ON THIS A BIT
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF FOLKS.
YORK OTHER TIME IN THE CITY CAN
ACTUALLY BUY A BUILDING TAKE
OVER BUILDING TURNED INTO A
PERMANENT FOR THE HOUSING
THAT'S WHAT BEEN TRYING TO DO
MORE. TO ACTUALLY SHOP SUCCESS
LET THEM BE RUN BY CAN BASED.
THE OFF TEN OFF VIA THE MISERY
OF OTHERS- SO THAT'S OUR MAIN
THRUST BUT I WILL COME BACK
JOHN THE S. R. O. LAW. NEXT WE
HAVE MARLA FROM WCBS EIGHT
EIGHTY. GOOD MORNING MR MAYOR I
HAVE BUT YOU QUESTIONS ONE
CONCERNING EDUCATION THE CITY
CONTROLLER WAS TALKING ABOUT
HOLDING CLASSES OUTSIDE HOW
FEASIBLE WOULD THIS BE OUR TO
DO IN NEW YORK CITY MARLA IT IS
SOMETHING WE WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF FOR SURE THE
CHANCELLOR'S BEEN VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THAT BUT IT'S NOT A
RELIABLE SOLUTION YOU GOT A
COUPLE OF PROBLEMS YOU GOT
RAIN. AND STORMS YOU GOT COLD
WEATHER- I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY IN SEPTEMBER OCTOBER YOU
MIGHT HAVE SOME OPPORTUNITY TO
SOME THINGS OUTSIDE. OUR I.
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY IN MAY
JUNE BY AISLE OF THE IT'S JUST
TOO COLD SOME FOLKS ARE SO
ROUSSEL OF BREWSTER. AND JUST A
REALITY THAT YOU GOT TO HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF RELIABILITY
CONSISTENCY WHEN YOU'RE RUNNING
A SCHOOL BOUGHT THAT SAID
SCHOOLS ARE WELCOME TO BE
FLEXIBLE THAT IF THERE'S GOOD
WEATHER AND THEY'VE GOT THE
RIGHT- OPPORTUNITY THE WAITER
SCHOOL SET UP AND THEY CAN GET
KIDS OUT AND WE'RE GONNA WORK
WITH SCHOOLS IN EACH AND EVERY
SITUATION TAKE ADVANTAGE AS
MUCH. WE CAN'T. THERE WERE
QUITE A BIT OF BLOWBACK ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. ABOUT YOUR ADVICE
NOT TO BUY A CAR WITH YOUR
CRITICS SAYING YOU AREN'T DOING
ANYTHING TO DISCOURAGE PEOPLE
FROM DRIVING IT DOES. HERE AT
ELDERLY ARE THAT ARE ARE
DRIVING AS THEY TRY TO STAY OFF
MASS TRANSIT. AND ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WAS YOU GET DRIVEN
AROUND AND SHOW FOR CAR HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO GET TO THE GYM IN
BROOKLYN ONCE IT REOPENS. YOU
KNOW MARLAND NOT PERTINENT TO
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH RIGHT
NOW RIGHT NOW WE ARE. IN WITH.
A CRISIS WHERE THE JOB ONE IS
TO GIVE PEOPLE CONFIDENCE A- IN.
AND I WANT TO SYRIAN STATE ARE
TOGETHER. TO SHOW THAT THE MTA
COULD BE A LOT CLEANER SUBWAYS
BUSES PEOPLE HAVE. ACT BY. BIG
ARTIST. FOR CALLING. OUT NOW.
NEW YORK. I IS THE WAY FORWARD
CLEAR I'M GOING. PEOPLE MAY USE
THEM IN THE SHORT TERM BECAUSE
THE CRISIS FINE BUT THERE'S A
CRISIS AGAIN THAT COULD BE OVER
IN A HALF YEAR GIVE OR TAKE
THEN WE HAVE CONTINUED TO
DEEPEN OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
MASS STRIKES ANOTHER OPTION
BECAUSE THAT'S THE FUTURE OF
THE CITY. WE HAVE TO EVER LEAVE
FROM MANHATTAN TIMES AND RANKS
FIFTH PRESS. TAKE A MORNING CAN
YOU HEAR ME YEAH THEY'RE REALLY
HOW YOU. I'M WELL THANKS GOOD
MORNING TO ALL OF WHICH YOU MAY
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT CONCERNS
RAISED BY STAFF AND TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS AND
SPECIFICALLY IT AND THE THREE
TWENTY FOUR IN WASHINGTON
HEIGHTS WHICH SERVICES. ABOUT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS-
CONCERN THAT THEY REDUCE THEIR
EMBLEMATIC OF MANY OF THE
CAMPUSES ACROSS THIRTY. DAY
FUND TO SCHOOL SAFETY COMMITTEE
AND THEY'RE EXPRESSING CONCERN
THAT- A PREVIOUS TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BUILDING FACILITIES
SUPPORT I'M FROM THE GOP AND
THE- AND INDEPENDENT ENGINEER
VALUATION SENSE EXHIBIT CAMPUS
INSULATION SYSTEMS AND.
ADDITIONAL CLASSROOMS. THAT AC
AT THE FOR SYSTEMS JUST DON'T
EXIST AND AGAIN ALTOGETHER THE
SYSTEM- IS EFFECTIVE ENOUGH
FROM INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS MADE
BY THE CITY AND THAT NUMBER.
FINISHING HAVE NOT. THEY ENTER
INTO NOW THE FINAL WEEKS OF
PREPARATION OTHER CONCERN IS
THAT THEY ARE IN FACT NOT READY
WHAT IS THE CITY DOING TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS
SPECIFICALLY DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THEIR RESERVATIONS ON THE
PART OF PARENTS- THE BUILDINGS
THEMSELVES WHAT IS THE DEAL WE
AND THE CITY DOING TO HELP
PREPARE- THE PHILIPPINES. TO BE
ABLE WHAT DOES THAT SAY THE
NUMBER OF THE SCHOOL AGAIN
DEFINITELY. AT THREE TWENTY
FOUR IN WASHINGTON HEIGHTS IT.
IS ABOUT FOURTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS YEAH THANK YOU. I'M
GOING TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE
CHANCELLOR TODAY ON THAT
SPECIFICALLY LOOK- THE BOTTOM
LINE HERE IS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON ALL FRONTS TO MAKE
SCHOOLS SAFE. ARE THERE A
VARIETY OF WAYS TO DO THAT. DO
NOT FORGET FOR A MOMENT. EVERY
CLASSROOM WILL BE SOCIALLY
DISTANCED EVERY PART OF THE
SCHOOL BE SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
CLASSROOM WILL HAVE TEN KIDS
TWELVE KIDS AND AT A VERY SMALL
NUMBER WITH DISTANCE EVERYONE
WILL HAVE A FACE COVERED. THE
STUDENTS AND ADULTS ALIKE.
CLEANING INCESSANTLY HAND
SANITIZER WHY HANDWASHING
STATIONS INCESSANTLY THERE'S A
LOT OF PIECES TO HOW YOU FIGHT
BACK DISEASE. SO WE ABSOLUTE
ONE MAKE SURE THAT THE
CIRCULATION SYSTEMS ARE IN GOOD
SHAPE IF THERE'S A SPECIFIC
PROBLEM IN THE SCHOOL THAT I
DEAL WITH THAT- BUT WILL BE
OPEN ABOUT THAT. THERE'S GOING
TO BE A LOT OF DIFFERENT PIECES
TO COME TOGETHER SO THANK YOU
FOR RAISING THIS AND WE'LL LOOK
INTO IT IMMEDIATELY BUT REST
ASSURED THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
PIECES THAT CREATE SAFETY FOR
KIDS GO AHEAD. HEY AT THE END
OF THE FOLLOW UP TO THAT OF
EXPRESS- HAS BEEN A AN
EXPLOSIVE IN THE CONCERN ON
GOING FOR PARENTS AND FAMILIES
ABOUT- NOT HAVING ADEQUATE
TECHNOLOGY RESOURCES EVEN AS
THEY FACE A CHOICE BETWEEN
BEING ONLINE- ARE FACING A
HYBRID MODEL. CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHAT THE CITY IN A DEAL WE HAVE
DONE IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS AND
FOR THAT MATTER WHAT. PARENTS
CAN DO IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS OF
PREPARATION TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS RESOURCES BECAUSE MANY
OF THE PARENTS THAT WERE
SPEAKING TO STILL CONTINUE. TO
BE STYMIED BY ACCESS TO ONLINE
LEARNING RESOURCES SO- LET ME
SAY THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT
POINT IS GETTING DEVICES AND
GETTING SERVICE. IN THE HANDS
OF EVERY CHILD WHO NEEDS IT.
THERE WAS A HERCULEAN AT.
NEOVIA DISTRIBUTED VERY SHORT
ORDER WHILE SETTING UP REMOTE
LEARNING FOR THE FIRST TIME AT
A MASS LEVEL LOOK AT THAT TO
EVERYONE WHO HAS A COMPLAINT
HAS A RIGHT TO COMPLAIN
EVERYTHING WE HAVE TO DO BETTER
AFTER THE BETTER BUT LET'S STOP
AND APPRECIATE OUR EDUCATORS.
AND THE DEAL WE AND ALL THE
COMPANIES GOT INVOLVED. THEY
WERE ASKED TO CREATE REMOTE
LEARNING FROM ONE POINT ONE
MILLION KIDS IN A MATTER OF
WEEKS FROM SCRATCH IT NEVER
BEEN- ANTICIPATED TO HAVE TO DO
IT ON THIS LEVEL THIS QUICKLY
IN THE HISTORY NEW YORK CITY
BUT THEY DID IT. IN PERFECT
YEAH BUT THEY DID AT THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND- DEVICES
DISTRIBUTED IN A MATTER OF
WEEKS I ONE OF MOST ACTUALLY
DIRECTS WAYS TO DRESS IN THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE WE ALL SEEN IT.
THREE BUT ANY KID ON VICE ONE
FOR FREE. EIGHT PRICE IS NOT
WORKING WILL BE REPLACED. IT
DOESN'T HAVE. YES. BY THE SAME
METHOD. G. OR LET THE ONLY DEAL
WE KNOW IF YOU. IT IS THERE.
ANYONE NOT SURE CAN SIMPLY CALL
THREE ONE ONE BUT THAT'S GOING
TO BE AN ONGOING EFFORT I'VE
HEARD A FEW PEOPLE SAY ALL OF
WHATEVER DEVICE BREAKS WE'LL
REPLACE IT. IT'S AS SIMPLE AS
THAT. NEXT WE HAVE EMMA FROM
THE NEW YORK TIMES. A
NIGHTMARE- I KNOW I'VE BEEN
HARPING ON THIS ISSUE BUT- I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT TESTING
AGAIN AND YOU WOULD ASK. NEED
TO GO TO A CITY SITE WE NEEDED
A TESTING AGAIN AND WE DID IT
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THE
RESULTS FOR TWO WEEKS THIRTEEN
VERY CRITICAL TO THE SCHOOL
PLANNED. TO HAVE TESTING AT AT
WHICH TURNAROUND TIME WHAT DO
YOU PARENTS WHO YOU KNOW KIT
HAS- THERE. YET. WELL FIRST. WE
DON'T KNOW WHERE THE BREAKDOWN
IS WHICH- COULD YOU DO YOU MIND
SAYING WHICH SIDE YOU WANT TO.
YEAH WE WENT TO HIGHBRIDGE POOL
WHICH IS THAT HEALTH NOT
GIRLFRIEND STATE BUT THEY SEND
THEIR CASTING TO QUEST
DIAGNOSTICS LAB WHICH
APPARENTLY IS THE ONE WITH THE
SLOWDOWN. RIGHT THAT'S WHERE
THE PROBLEM IS SPOKE TO THE C.
E. OF. THIS YESTERDAY WE HAD A
VERY PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION.
ARE YOU AN OTHERS WENT THROUGH
SOMETHING ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE. IT WAS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE MASSIVE OVERLOAD
THAT OCCURRED ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY. THE COMBINATION OF THE
HUGE UPTICK IN THE DISEASE AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY. AND
ACTUALLY ALSO IRONICALLY A LOT
OF BUSINESSES COMING BACK AND
PUTTING VERY INTENSE TESTING
PROGRAMS INTO PLACE. SO WHAT
HAPPENED WAS QUESTIONS GOT
OVERLOOKED ON THE COUNTRY AND
THEY ARE MORE SPREADER AND
THEY- RESOLVE THE LAW. QUESTS
TURNAROUND FOR YORK CITY WILL
GET TO FOUR DAYS OR LESS. ON
THAT YOU KNOW WE OBVIOUSLY WANT
ONE DAY TO DAY THAT'S ALWAYS
OUR GOAL BUT FOUR DAYS LAST
WEEK WORK WITH- BUT THE CEO WAS
QUITE CLEAR. THE WORST IS
EYEING THEM THEY'VE HAD A LOT
OF CAPACITY IN WHICH BUT NOT
THE THAT PROBLEM AGAIN BUT I.
SORRY IT IN ANYONE I WENT
THROUGH. GO AHEAD NOT. BUT I
THREE IT BUT IN TERMS IF IT IF
FOUR DAYS YOUR EXPECTING IF THE
CHILD SHOW SINCE THEN ANYTHING
THAT RELATED TO COVID. IT WOULD
EITHER HELP THEIR CHILD HOME
FOR THOSE FOUR DAYS- UNTIL THEY
CAN CONFIRM THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE BACK CORRECT. YEAH ANY
TIME YOU CAESAR COMES. WE WANT
IN FACT WE INSIST THAT FAMILIES
I'M SAYING THIS AS A PARENT. I
ABIDE BY THIS IN A HEARTBEAT I
HAVE CHECKED EVERY PARENT TO
BYE BYE YOUR CHILD SICK IN YOUR
CHILD'S ON THE SYMPTOMS KEEP
YOUR CHILD HOME. KEEP YOUR TO
THEY ARE ALL AND ALL. BEST I
NEVER COMES NEGATIVE GRADE
COMES BACK POSITIVE YOU GOT TO
GO THROUGH THE WHOLE COURSE OF-
THAT PAUSE UNTIL YOU COME BACK.
NEXT WE HAVE HENRY FROM
BLOOMBERG. HELLO MR MAYOR HOW
YOU DOING TODAY I'M DOING OKAY
HENRY HOW BOUT YOU. I'M DOING
PRETTY WELL I WANNA GET BACK I
MEAN HAVE YOU HEARD FROM THE
GOVERNOR ON WHAT HIS DECISION
IS GOING TO BE OR IS HE WITH
HOLDING THIS AS A BIG SURPRISE
I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM AS OF SAID
HENRY- FIRST OF ALL HE SAID
HE'D GIVEN AN OUNCE AS SOME
POINT TODAY THE- I. KNOW I CAN
BE A- OUR TEAM TO TALK CONST
REALLY COSTLY WHOLE HOST OF
THINGS I AND I DO UNDERSTAND
THE GOVERNOR HAS TO THINK ABOUT
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
REGIONS IN THE STATE THAT'S A
REAL- REAL OBLIGATION THAT I
FELT UNDERSTATE. ABOUT I'M SURE
WE'LL HEAR IN THE COURSE OF THE
DAY AND- WE WELCOME TOUGH
STANDARDS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
WE EVEN HERE I'VE- SAID
PROACTIVELY WE WANNA HOLD
OURSELVES THAT'S 3% STANDARD
THAT'S- MUCH LOWER THAN ANY
OTHER STANDARD I'VE HEARD
AROUND THE COUNTRY. BUT WE
BELIEVE NEW YORK CITY IS UP TO
THAT BECAUSE OF HOW WELL WE'VE
DONE OVER THE LAST TWO MONTHS
KEEPING THE INFECTION LEVEL
DOWN. GO AHEAD AND- THE GIRL.
ALSO SAID THAT. TWO MAJOR
CONSIDERATIONS ARE THE RENTAL
AND UNION BY IT. AND FROM
RECORDING THAT I'VE DONE AND
OTHERS HAVE DONE THE UNIONS ARE
STILL EXTREMELY SKEPTICAL AND
FEARFUL REALLY ABOUT HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES AND SUBJECTING
TEACHERS. TO THE CLASSROOM AND
PARENTS ARE ALSO SKEPTICAL
NUMBER ONE THAT THE REMOTE
LEARNING EXPERIENCE HAS REALLY
BEEN- IMPROVED TO THE POINT
WHERE IT'S GOING TO ENGAGE
STUDENTS IN ON THE THEY'VE GOT.
CONCERNS ABOUT THE HEALTH CAN'T
AND SENDING THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL SUFFERING IN LIGHT OF
ALL THAT. DOES IT CAUSE YOU ANY
CONCERN THAT- THE GOVERNOR WILL
DECIDE NOT TO GO ALONG WITH
YOUR PLANT HENRY I'M NOT GOING
TO SPECULATE I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS NANA'S QUESTION DOES
NOTHING SPECULATE DOESN'T GET
US ANYWHERE- THE GOVERNOR COME
TO US I'LL DECISION WE WILL
WORK WITH THAT NOW THE PARENT
BY AND THIS IS A KNOWN FACT GET
RISK FREE ONE UP ONE WHEN WE
EXCEPTIONAL PIECE FROM. HE'S
GIVEN HIS DUE. WITHOUT PEOPLE
RESPOND TO A SURVEY AND 75% SAY
THEY WANT THEIR KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL DR HUGE NUMBER OF
PARENTS MYSELF EVERYWHERE I GO
I MAKE SURE TO TALK TO PARENTS
OF ACT TALKED A LOT EDUCATORS
TO. I GET OVERWHELMINGLY THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO COME BACK AT NO
ONE UNDERESTIMATES THE
CHALLENGES BUT THE NEW YORKERS
THEY'RE TOUGH STRONGER
RESILIENT THEY ALL THESE OTHER
GOOD PEOPLE OUT THERE FIVE. FOR
THE FELONY HEAH CARE HEROES
ARE RESPONDENTS TEACHERS ARE
INCREDIBLY DEVOTED PEOPLE IF I
TELL YOU A LIE EDUCATORS AND
SAID TO ME. I CAN'T DO A MUCH
TO THE- REMOTELY I WANT TO BE
THERE IN PERSON WITH THEM
BECAUSE I CAN'T HELP THEM IF
I'M SO FAR AWAY FROM THEM. AND
I REALLY HONOR THAT ABOUT
EDUCATORS. ARE SO I THINK WE
HAVE A HUGE LEVEL PARENT BIDEN
BASED ON WHAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR
BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A FAX
FOR YOU ON MONDAY BECAUSE
PARENTS GET TO MAKE THAT.
VISION DATE THE FOR. ROUND AND
WHILE THAT WILL TELL. HI AND
THEN WHAT WE BUT WHEN YOU.
DAILY OUR TO A THE WHOLE OF
ISSUE AND INSTALL TIME ON THE
CLOCK HERE TO KEEP ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES SO. I FEEL
STRONGLY WE CAN BRING THE
PIECES TOGETHER- BECAUSE RIGHT
DO IS WRITE YOUR KIDS IS
WRITING TO DO FOR OUR CITY AND
WE'RE GONNA KEEP WORKING TO
MAKE SURE IT'S SAFE. LAST YOU
FOR TODAY. NEXT WE HAVE GERSH
FROM STREETS BLOG. THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE CALL IT'S ABOUT
THE ASKED ONE OF THE EASIEST
MOST BASIC QUESTIONS I'VE EVER
ASKED YOU ON THIS CALL ON
FRIDAY MAY TWENTY NINTH POLICE
COMMISSIONER SHEA WAS ASKED
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF POLICE
OFFICERS LIVE IN THE SUBURBS HE
SAID HE DIDN'T KNOW THE NUMBER
OFF HAND WHICH IS FINE AND
ASKED REPORTERS TO CALL THE
NYPD'S PRESS OFFICER THAT
NUMBER. MR OUTLET AND THEN
AFTER THAT NUMBER SIX TIMES AND
OTHER REPORTERS HAVE. WE HAVE
NO GOTTEN THAT NUMBER DOESN'T
BOTHER YOU THAT THE NYPD PRESS
ALT WON'T ANSWER THIS BASIC
QUESTION AMONG OTHERS IT DOES.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE ASKING IT NOT
MAKES NO SENSE- WE KNOW TWO
CRUCIAL THINGS ABOUT TODAY'S
NYPD IT IS A MAJORITY PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AND IS MORE AND MORE NEW
YORK CITY RESIDENTS. ARE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WE'RE GETTING
CLOSE TO A BREAK EVEN POINT IN
TERMS OF FOLKS LIVE IN THE CITY
VERSUS SUBURBS BUT I WANT TO
GET THE EXACT NUMBERS WE WILL.
DO THAT NOW TODAY EVEN IF IT'S-
CLOSE ESTIMATE WE'LL GET YOU
THAT. BUT NOT. YOUR AVAILABLE
TO YOUR OVER SIDE OF THE NYPD
SO MAYOR LAST YEAR YOU
RESPONDED TO REPORTS OF
RECKLESS DRIVING BY NYPD
OFFICERS BY PLEDGING TO REVOKE
PARKING PERMITS FOR COPS TO GET
TOO MANY CAMERA ISSUED SPEEDING
TICKETS THAT MEMOIR JUST LAST
MONTH FINALLY TURN YOUR PROMISE
INTO POP THE BY UPDATING THE
PATROL GUIDE NOW TURNS OUT
ACCORDING TO THE PATROL GUIDE
THAT A COP HAS TO GET FIFTEEN
CAMERA TWO SPEEDING TICKETS. IN
ONE YEAR BEFORE IN HIS PARKING
PERMIT I ASK YOU TEAM. SPEED
TICKETS TWELVE MONTHS THE
THRESHER YOU ONE WHEN YOU
REVIEW. NOT AS THERE ARE IN
CIVILIAN USE OF THEIR CAR NOW I
DO WHAT I NEED TO GET CLEARLY
WILL GET YOU THIS ANSWER IS IF
PD WAS PUTTING THAT NUMBER IN
BECAUSE THEY KNOW A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF THE TIME IT'S IN
THE LINE OF DUTY OR PEOPLE ARE
RUSHING TO A JOB THAT'S ONE
THING. BYE IF OUT CIVILIAN USE.
THAT WILL COME BACK. LAST ONE
FOR TODAY WE HAVE REFRAINED
FROM HARMONIA. GOOD MORNING MR
MAYOR I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU
ABOUT YOUR COMMENTS YESTERDAY.
GOVERNOR'S INTEREST IN
ACCOMMODATING THE WEALTHY NEW
YORKERS WHO WANTED TO LEAVE YOU
FREQUENTLY MENTION HOW HOW HOW
BAD THE CITY'S THE OF
MAGISTRATES ALL RIGHT. LOSING
WEALTHY PEOPLE ONE BOTH
TAXPAYER. GOING THERE THE
BUDGETING MORE. IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT I'M TRYING TO
SAY FIRST OF ALL LET'S FOCUS ON
WORKING PEOPLE. LET'S FOCUS ON
MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO DO THEIR JOBS EVERY
DAY ARE FIGHTING TO GET THEIR
JOBS BACK WHO NEED HELP WHO ARE
THE- BACKBONE OF THE CITY THE
HEART AND SOUL IN NEW YORK CITY
THEY'RE NOT GONE ANYWHERE
THEY'RE NOT FLEEING. THIS IS
NEW YORK. AND IT IS A NEW
YORKERS I'M HERE TO FIGHT FOR.
THE WEALTHY HAVE BECOME MORE-
GLOBAL IN MANY WAYS NOT BECAUSE
OF THIS CRISIS LONG BEFORE.
MUCH LESS ROOTED. THEY WILL
COME THEY WILL GO. SOME ARE
TRULY YORKERS WE GOT A LOT OF
HOMEGROWN MILLIONAIRES HERE
THAT'S GREAT I KNOW A LOT OF
REALLY CARE ABOUT NEW YORK CITY
AND DO A LOT FOR YORK CITY GOD
BLESS THEM. THE FOLKS WHO WANT
TO BE A PART OF THIS. COMMUNITY
BLOSSOM AND THEY'VE DONE WELL
IN LIFE ADULATION IS NOW LET'S
HELP OUT OTHER PEOPLE. BUT I AM
NOT GOING TO BEG ANYBODY TO
LIVE IN THE GREATEST CITY IN
THE WORLD. THERE ARE PLENTY OF
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO LIVE IN NEW
YORK CITY THERE ARE PLENTY OF
PEOPLE COME HERE NO MATTER
WHAT. THIS CRISIS WILL BE OVER
SOON. AND HERE'S WHAT WE FOUND
WE ACTUALLY ANALYZE THIS. IN
RECENT YEARS SOME MILLIONAIRES
AND BILLIONAIRES HAVE LEFT.
SOME MILLIONAIRES AND
BILLIONAIRES HAVE COME IN. AND
STARTED TO GROW ROOTS HERE IN
YOUR- AT IT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT FOR. HAS BRED MORE
MILLIONAIRES EVERY YEAR IN
RECENT YEARS THAN EVER BEFORE
BECAUSE UP TILL FEBRUARY OUR
ECONOMY WAS BOOMING AND PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD WANTED
TO COME HERE SENSING
OPPORTUNITY AND THEY WILL AGAIN.
SO I AM CONVINCED. THAT BY
FOCUSING ON IT WAS RESTORING
THIS CITY AND DOING WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR WORKING PEOPLE IN THE
CITY. IT WILL BE A BETTER A
BETTER AND FAIRER PLACE I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT'S WHERE
CREATIVE PEOPLE WANT TO BE
ENTREPRENEURIAL PEOPLE WANT TO
BE AND THAT'S OUR BACK. GO
AHEAD. AND YOUR DESIRED TO
RAISE TAXES EVEN FURTHER ON THE
WEALTHY THE WEALTHY 1% OF NEW
YORKERS ALREADY PAY MORE THAN
40% OF THE TOTAL OF PERSONAL
INCOME TAXES PAID IN THE STATE.
HOW MUCH IS. IT IS IT ENOUGH.
LOOK I'LL SIMPLY GO BACK TO. IF
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT FAIR
TAXATION IN AMERICA AND WHEN
AMERICA WORKS MOST FAIRLY AND
EQUITABLY UNQUESTIONABLY IS THE
PERIOD AFTER WORLD WAR TWO UP
THROUGH THE NINETEEN SO HE'S WE
SAW A HUGE AMOUNT OF ECONOMIC
GROWTH WE SAW MUCH LESS INCOME
INEQUALITY WE SAW EVERY DAY
PEOPLE GETTING A PIECE OF THE
PIE AND WORKING AWAY THE MIDDLE
CLASS. WAS GOVERNMENT VET. IT
HEALTH CARE IN SCIENCE RESEARCH
EDUCATION AND THE HIGHEST TAX
RATES THAT WEALTHY PEOPLE EVER
EXPERIENCED ONE DAY
ADMINISTRATION OF THAT WELL
KNOWN LEFT WING SOCIALIST
GENERAL DWIGHT EISENHOWER SO I
HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT WE HAD
THE MODEL RIGHT AT ONE POINT
AND WE LOST OUR WAY AND WE NEED
TO GO BACK TO A MODEL THE LAST
TIME THE WEALTHY. FARESHARE A
COUNTRY CAN INVEST IN ITS
PEOPLE. EVERYBODY LOOK LET ME
CLOSE TODAY WITH THIS WE TALKED
ABOUT A LOT OF DIFFERENT TOPICS
THE MOST IMPORTANT TOPIC ALWAYS
IS FIGHTING BACK THIS DISEASE.
ARE THE PEOPLE HAVE DONE THIS
IN NEW YORK CITY YOU'RE GOING
TO HEAR CONVERSATION ALL THE
TIME ABOUT WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
DID THE CITY THE STATE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT MATTERS
MUCH MORE PART IS WHAT THE
PEOPLE DO. THE BUY IN OF THE
PEOPLE THE STRENGTH OF THE
PEOPLE THE BELIEF OF THE PEOPLE
ARE THAT WE COULD FIGHT BACK
NEW YORK HASN'T SHOWN IT. WOULD
BE THEIR VOICE BUT THE PEOPLE
THIS IS MIKE TESTING SONG FOR
ARE GIVING PEOPLE ANY. THE
SERVER. IF YOU NEED TO SAFELY
SEPARATE KNOWING YOU'RE NOT.
YOU'RE GONNA GET ALL THE HELP
YOU NEED. AND THE PEOPLE ALSO
CAN REMIND EACH OTHER INCLUDING
ANY OF OUR FRIENDS WHO ARE
TRAVELING OR FAMILY MEMBERS
COMING HERE. THAT THIS
QUARANTINE FOR FOLKS HAVE BEEN
OUT OF STATE REALLY MATTERS SO
I HAVE FAITH IN THE PEOPLE. NO
ONE WANTS TO SEE THE CITY GO
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE IN THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HORRIBLE
CRISIS. IN FACT NEW YORKER
APPROVE IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
THAT WAY BECAUSE OF YOUR HARD
WORK LET'S KEEP DOING IT.
THANKS EVERYBODY.